die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend Fußball
gibt es gleich von Rudi zerner hallo
schönen guten Abend unsere großen Themen
heute
nach dem Aus für Staatssekretär reichen
die Ampel streitet über den Zeitplan
beim geplanten heizungsgesetz
vor dem Gipfel in Japan verschärfen die
G7 ihre Sanktionen gegen Russland und
wie entgegnen sie den Machtstreben
Chinas
und eine besondere Siegesserie im Finale
des DFB-Pokals schlagen die
Wolfsburgerin Freiburg und holen sich
damit den 9 Titeln folgen
bis zur Sommerpause soll das umstrittene
heizungsgesetz verabschiedet werden so
der Plan aber der Plan wackelt der nach
der Entlassung von
wirtschaftsstaatssekretär reichen tritt
die FDP auf die Bremse da greifen
maßgeblich für das Gesetz zuständig war
SPD und Grüne dagegen wollen weiter am
Zeitplan festhalten über die Debatte
Christiane hübscher
Millionen Deutscher Häuser mit neuen
Heizungen klimafit machen das würden die
Grünen gerne bis zum Juli beschließen
doch nach dem Rückzug von Staatssekretär
reichen hält der Koalitionspartner FDP
habecks gesetzeszeitplan für nicht mehr
haltbar natürlich kann man ein Gesetze
durchpeitschen aber unser Ziel muss doch
sein dass wir die Menschen bei diesem
für alle sehr schwierigen Gesetz auch
mitnehmen und das erreichen wir nicht
dadurch dass wir uns selbst zeitlich
unter Druck setzen
Verzögerungstaktik nennen das die Grünen
und fordern Verlässlichkeit in der Ampel
ein diese Verlässlichkeit die verlange
ich auch von der FDP alle haben die
Zustimmung dazu erteilt im
Koalitionsausschuss im Kabinett jetzt
ist es an den Fraktionen dass wir bis
zum Sommer das Gesetz auch verabschiedet
kriegen kommt das umstrittene Gesetz
müssten ab 2024 massenhaft alte Öl und
Gasheizungen zum Beispiel durch
Wärmepumpen ersetzt werden die Union
fordert stattdessen einen richtigen
Neustart er warte von Minister habe ich
dass er jetzt einfach mal auf die Taste
drückt dass er nicht mit der Brechstange
versucht ein Gesetz durchzudrücken da
muss man jetzt in alle Ruhe im Sinne des
Klimaschutzes ein ordentliches Gesetz
machen die SPD hält es mit den Grünen
sieht keinen Grund zu verschieben ich
sehe nicht was es sachlich miteinander
zu tun hat dass der Abgang von Patrick
reichen jetzt dazu führen soll dass wir
kein Gebäude Energiegesetz mehr machen
Minister Habeck muss derweil schnell
eine Nachfolger für seinen geschassten
Staatssekretär finden dessen Trauzeuge
der nun ohne Job da steht teilt heute
mit dass er auf die angebotene Abfindung
verzichtet wenn Robert Habeck dachte das
gestern war ein Befreiungsschlag dann
sieht er sich wohl getäuscht
und nach der Entlassung von Patrick
reichen muss das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium erneut in
die Offensive gehen und weiß Kritik an
einem weiteren Staatssekretär an Udo
Philipp zurück das Ministerium
veröffentlichte eine Liste aller
direkten Unternehmensbeteiligungen von
Philipp habe den Aktien besitzt
angezeigt obwohl er es nicht hätte tun
müssen außerdem habe er nicht über
finanzielle Förderungen der Startups
entschieden
in die Ukraine wo das Land eigenen
Angaben zufolge mehrere russische
Raketen und Drohnenangriffe abgewehrt
hat auch auf die Hauptstadt Kiew dort
lösten die Trümmer abgefangener
Flugkörper einen Brand aus laut
ukrainischen Behörden ist es der 9
russische Luftangriff auf Kiew seit
Anfang des Monats
im süd-ukrainischen Odessa ist ein
Mensch durch herabstürzende Teile einer
abgeschossenen Rakete getötet worden
zwei weitere wurden verletzt
und der russische Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine zählt auch zu den
Hauptthemen des g7-treffens in Japan zu
den sieben großen Wirtschaftsmächten
gehören die USA Kanada Frankreich
Großbritannien Deutschland Italien und
Japan sie beraten am Morgen in Hiroshima
unter anderem über Schäfer Sanktionen
gegen Russland auch das Verhältnis des
Westens zu China wird beim Gipfel eine
Rolle spielen und Roller berichtet
Hiroshima die Welt blickt auf diese
Stadt die G7 starten Tagen hier gut
bewacht an eine historischen Ort an die
Tragik erinnert das Friedensdenkmal das
Wahrzeichen der Stadt die die Atombombe
zerstörte
sie verbannen die Atombombe oder
zumindest machen Sie Schritte zur
nuklearen Abrüstung
Ankunft des Bundeskanzlers ein Gipfel in
schwierigen Zeiten der Angriffskrieg
Russlands bedroht den Frieden unter
anderem wollen die G7 Staaten den
Diamantenhandel eine wichtige
Einnahmequelle für Russland
sanktionieren und sie wollen eine
Botschaft in die Welt aussenden
wird auch hier wieder eine zentrale
Rolle spielen klar zu machen dass die
Einsatz von Atomwaffen im Krieg nicht
zugelassen ist und das ist eine
Katastrophe für die ganze Menschheit
wäre
Präsident beiden machte auf einem
US-Stützpunkt in Japan einen
Zwischenstopp auf dem Weg nach Hiroshima
Amerika fühlt sich als Schutzmacht in
der Region
anschließend treffen mit dem Gastgeber
dem japanischen Premierminister kishida
beide Regierungschefs sind sich einig
Russlands Angriffskrieg dürfe der Westen
nicht hinnehmen
wie unterstützen die Ukraine sie
verteidigt ihre Souveränität wir werden
Russland zur Verantwortung ziehen
die Regierungschefs werden morgen den
Friedenspark besuchen dort können sie
spüren welche verheerenden folgendes hat
wenn Politik versagt
in ihrer Chima ist für uns MRT Wissen
Emma zum g7-gipfel sind ja auch Indien
Brasilien und Indonesien eingeladen
warum
das ist gewissermaßen auch so etwas wie
eine Werbeveranstaltung hier die G7
brauchen den sogenannten globalen Süden
unter anderem zum Beispiel um die
Schlupflöcher bei den Sanktionen gegen
Russland zu stopfen ein Beispiel Indien
ist der größte Bearbeiter von russischen
Rohdiamanten wenn man also den
Diamantenhandel mit Russland
einschränken will dann braucht man eben
Indien das mitziehen muss und die G7
wollen eben diesen Ländern Brasilien in
Indien und anderen auch erklären warum
sie eine schärfere Gangart gegenüber
China einschlagen weil wie sie sagen
chinesische Firmen weiterhin den
Angriffskrieg von Putin unterstützen
weil Peking andere Länder erpresst mit
wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten und weil
es den Frieden und die Sicherheit im
Indopazifik gefährdet aber die Länder
des globalen Südens jedenfalls viele
sehen in China einen wichtigen und
verlässlichen Handelspartner und fühlen
sich von den G7 diesem elitären Club in
der Vergangenheit im Stich gelassen und
um das zu ändern bieten eben die G7
jetzt eben diesen Platz am Tisch hier an
und darüber hinaus
passive Unterstützung diesen Ländern bei
der Lösung ihrer Probleme ob das reicht
das werden wir sehen danke MRT wissen
nach Deutschland vor genau 175 Jahren
trat in der Frankfurter Paulskirche die
Nationalversammlung zusammen es war die
erste Sitzung eines gewählten
gesamtdeutschen Parlaments und die
Abgeordneten hat meine große Aufgabe
dass er arbeiten einer freiheitlichen
Verfassung für ganz Deutschland am Ende
trat die Verfassung nie in Kraft wegen
des Widerstands des preußischen Königs
und einiger Fürsten aber sie prägte
sowohl die Weimarer Verfassung als auch
das Grundgesetz von 1949 mehr von Delia
Thomas
Europa 1848 in verschiedenen großen
Städten gibt es revolutionsbewegungen
die Aufbruchstimmung erfasst auch den
Deutschen Bund einen Zusammenschluss vom
Kaiserreich Österreich von Königreichen
Grafschaften Fürsten und Herzogtümern
und den freien Städten die Menschen auf
den Straßen fordern Demokratie Freiheit
und die Schaffung eines Nationalstaates
die Frankfurter Paulskirche wird zum
Zentrum der politischen Ereignisse denn
am 18 mai 1848 treten hier die knapp 600
Abgeordneten der deutschen
Nationalversammlung erstmalig zusammen
in ihrer kurzen Amtszeit legen Sie
grundlegende Menschen und Bürgerrechte
fest die Gleichheit aller vor dem Gesetz
unabhängig von ihrer sozialen Herkunft
und persönliche und politische
Freiheitsrechte wie versammlungs- und
Meinungsfreiheit und Pressefreiheit
diese Rechte sind für Landesverfassungen
und das Grundgesetz bis heute prägend
die Paulskirche wurde also zur Wiege der
deutschen Demokratie und so gab es dort
heute ein Festakt mit dem
Bundespräsidenten dabei schlug
Steinmeier auch eine Verbindung zur
Gegenwart das Pauls Kirchenjubiläum zu
feiern sei auch ein Zitat Zeichen gegen
die Verächter unserer parlamentarischen
Demokratie über den Festtag berichtet
Peter Tyson
festliche Stimmung an dem Ort an dem
heute vor 175 Jahren die erste deutsche
Nationalversammlung zusammentrat sich in
diese Zeit zurückversetzen auch das ist
heute möglich dank moderner Technik ich
bitteschön
mithilfe von originalprotokollen aus
dieser Zeit konnten Historiker die
Ereignisse von damals rekonstruieren in
der Paulskirche erinnert der
Bundespräsident daran wie wichtig der
Einsatz für Demokratie und Freiheit auch
heute ist wer heute Parlamente verhöhnt
ständig von dem System von
Gleichschaltung und Meinungsdiktatur
spricht der verhöhnt in Wahrheit
diejenigen die für Freiheit und
Demokratie gekämpft haben
das Fest heute mit zehntausenden
Besuchern auch eine Art
Selbstvergewisserung in Sachen
Demokratie auch wenn sie immer wieder in
Frage gestellt oder angegriffen wird
Frankfurt zeigt heute die große Mehrheit
die ist demokratisch ja ich denke dass
Deutschland gut mit der Demokratie dran
ist aber zum Beispiel müsste man mal
dringend den Bundestag reformieren und
verkleinern an sich glaube ich dass
unsere Demokratie ganz gut ist und auch
gut funktioniert
wir aber trotzdem weiter alle dafür
kämpfen müssen dass es auch so bleibt
die Überzeugung des Bundespräsidenten
wenn irgendwo auf der Welt die Freiheit
angegriffen wird dann ist das immer auch
ein Angriff auf unsere Freiheit darum
helfen wir den angegriffenen Menschen
die der Ukraine und wir unterstützen wie
wenigen mutigen die sich in Russland
gegen die unterdrücke auflehnen heute
erinnert das Fest in Frankfurt daran
dass Demokratie und Freiheit nicht
selbstverständlich sind und von jeder
Generation von neuem verteidigt werden
müssen
in den Überschwemmungsgebieten in
Italien herrschen weiterhin Chaos und
Verzweiflung von mindestens 11 Toten ist
inzwischen die Rede die Schäden sollen
in die Milliarden gehen während manche
zurückkehren können und vor den Trümmern
ihrer Existenz stehen werden anderen
Orts noch Menschen in Sicherheit
gebracht
betroffen ist die Region Emilia Romania
mit ihrer Hauptstadt Bologna die
verschwinden Gebiete liegen östlich
davon Gnade Adria
sie kommen um auch die letzten aus dem
Hochwasser und einem Meer aus Müll zu
befreien viele alte Menschen haben es in
cesina nicht rechtzeitig aus ihren
Wohnungen und Häusern geschafft aber
Nachbarschaftshilfe ist unterwegs
viele sind entsetzt wie schnell das
Wasser kam und jetzt ist das meiste
kaputt
wir haben noch überlegt wie wir die
Eingangstür für barrikadieren und dann
kam das Wasser schon durch die Rückseite
rein
wir haben kein Wasser kein Strom kein
Essen nichts
dort wo das Wasser zurückgeht sind die
Menschen entsetzt über das Ausmaß der
Schäden die Regionalregierung spricht
von Milliarden Euro und fordert schnelle
Hilfe
32 Jahre sind die Fotos Alt Fotos von
der Hochzeitsgesellschaft von Sunny und
Cola Rafaela ein verdrecktes Fotobuch
mit schönen Erinnerungen
wie kann man etwas aufbewahren das so
aussieht Sanierer ist geschockt und
überlegt was sie mit ihren
Erinnerungsstücken machen sollen
der österreichische Schauspieler Helmut
Berger glänzte vor allem in
exzentrischen Rollen jetzt starb er im
Alter von 78 Jahren in Salzburg zur Welt
Rom gelangte Berger über seine
Zusammenarbeit mit dem italienischen
Regisseur lucino Visconti für die na zu
einer Art männlicher Mose wurde Ludwig
II in dem man an der Seite von Romy
Schneider spielte gehört zu seinen
bekanntesten Filmen ein anderer
Klassiker das Bildnis des Dorian Gray ab
den 80er Jahren übernahm Berger kaum
noch größere Rollen
und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport und da
gab es ja spektakuläre Tore im Fußball
genau bei den Frauen und bei den Männern
die Fußballerinnen des VfL Wolfsburg
feiern den 10 DFB-Pokalsieg insgesamt
die Mannschaft von Trainer Tommy Stroth
die mit vielen Nationalspielerinnen
besetzt ist besiegen den SC Freiburg in
Köln vor einer Rekordkulisse von 44.000
Fans mit vier zu eins
Kapitän in Alexandra Popp ist beteiligt
am frühen 1:0 der Wolfsburgerinnen doch
es ist ein unglückliches Eigentor der
Freiburgerin Lisa Karl knapp vor Pop am
Ball kurz vor der Pause aber kommt
Freiburg
zum Kopfball der Ausgleich für den
Außenseiter nach dem
wechselpfostenschutz Wolfsburg durch
pajor und dann bekommt plombies zwei
Versuche zum 2:1 die erneute Führung
durch die Schwedin Rebecca blondes
ein zu Unrecht gegebener Eckball leitet
die Entscheidung ein Alexandra Popp
zeigt ihre Kopfballstärke das 3:1 einen
Handelfmeter verwandelt Dominik Jansen
schließlich zum 4:1 entstand der VfL
Wolfsburg holt sich Pokalsieg Nummer 10
ein deutscher Rekord
[Musik]
dann jetzt zu den Männern nach dem
Finaleinzug in der Champions League
überschlagen sich die Medien mit Lob für
Manchester City und Trainer pep
Guardiola sein Team hatte gestern im
Halbfinale Rückspiel Real Madrid mit
14:0 abgefertigt als Antreiber war pep
Guardiola fast nicht von Nöten sein Team
motiviert bis in die Haarspitzen
Torjäger Holland zwar mehrfach im Pech
aber dafür springt eine andere ein
Bernardo Silber der Portugiese zum 1:0
auf Zuspiel von de Bräune und nach
Vorarbeit ist überragenden günor mit
Köpfchen zur zwei zu null Pausenführung
die Niederlage gegen Real im Vorjahr hat
mir bis heute Magenschmerzen verursacht
diese Schmerzen dürften jetzt Madrid
plagen der Lattentreffer von groß die
beste Gelegenheit des Titel Verteidigers
ob das 13:0 akanji zugeschrieben werden
soll oder ein Eigentor war egal der Sieg
von ManCity auch in der Höhe verdient
Alvares zum 4:0 das Team und sein
Maestro an der Außenlinie auf direktem
Kurs Richtung Champions League
ja und das Finale gegen Inter Mailand
dann am 10 Juni hier bei uns im ZDF das
wollte ich nur sagen
scheint an der Nordsee die Sonne
Peter wolkig in den Alpen sind am
Nachmittag einzelne Schauer möglich die
Temperatur steigt auf 14 bis 21 Grad in
den nächsten Tagen steigt die Temperatur
deutlich an zu Wochenbeginn gibt es 21
bis 30 Grad allerdings auch kräftige
Gewitter
das heute journal mit Christian Sievers
können Sie um 21:45 Uhr sehen und morgen
steht an dieser Stelle Barbara halweg
bis bald
[Musik]
morgen scheint an der Nordsee die Sonne
sonst ist es meist heiter später wolkig
in den Alpen sind am Nachmittag einzelne
Schauer möglich die Temperatur steigt
auf 14 bis 21 Grad in den nächsten Tagen
steigt die Temperatur deutlich an zu
Wochenbeginn gibt es 21 bis 30 Grad
allerdings auch kräftige Gewitter